hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft maul wie ihr wisst haben
wir jede folge eine neue challenge und
wir befinden uns jetzt erstmal in
minecraft zusammen mit markus hallo max
und bevor wir zu den tisch kommen möchte
ich euch erst mal ganz kurz zeigen was
wir alles noch kurz of screen ja wir
haben ein bisschen off spiel noch weiter
gebaut wir haben dort nämlich dieses
haus hier fertig gestellt ich habe hier
oben noch mein glas das letzte glas dran
verbaut dass ich hier oben diese teile
fertig gekriegt habe hier oben kennen
wir jetzt da hinten geht die sonne unter
hier können wir unterlaufen und hier ist
unsere kleine farm hier ist unsere
arbeit ecke und vorne haben wir ein paar
schafe sich gegenseitig habe liebe
machen lassen haben noch kleine schafe
ja also noch kleineren wo sich unser
haus von vorne aus also jetzt auch nicht
so viel aber wir wollten auf jeden fall
so ein bisschen was machen so dass wir
in dieser folge max wollen wir dieser
folge machen luca muss in dieser folge
allgemein wissensfragen beantworten ich
fragte ihn versuchen und wenn er es
falsch hat muss er sachen aus seinem
inventar wegschmeißen wir wissen selbst
ist es jetzt nicht wie bei war oh so
dass man wenn man sein schwert verliert
einfach komplett dran interessen
ich bin übels frau ulrike ich hab die
ganze zeit of scilly die schafe und die
kühe gezüchteten klassenfahrten okay ich
hab die mal wieder gelingt gepaart du
stellst mir jetzt quasi allgemeinwissen
fragen und wenn ich eine frage nicht
richtig beantwortet sagst du mir eine
zahl oder irgendwas und das schmeiße ich
auf meinem inventar zu machen wir ich
muss dazu sagen dass ich solche sachen
eigentlich nie richtig beantworten kann
ich bereich der dümmste mensch der welt
na ja also wir fangen mal ganz leicht an
wie lautet die hauptstadt von frankreich
das ist jetzt nicht ernsthaft
doch wir fangen ganz leicht an wir
machen so ein kleines quiz paris ja aber
ich darf meine sachen behalten
lukat hier unten auf den
cool sage ich mal in dem wir aufgefangen
werden denn wir runter springt plötzlich
karte beschwert das wetter einfach oder
ja ich zeige den leuten immer ganz kurz
diesem pool habe ich einfach so ein
bisschen erweitert und da vorne so ein
bisschen was zu gebaut aber ja du
wolltest mir ne frage stellen welche
agent steht im zusammenhang mit der
lizenz zum töten
james bond richtig ja die bisher gehen
die fragen also ich dachte jetzt kommt
wirklich irgend sowas krasses so aber
bisher gibt es klar das wäre natürlich
auch scheiße wenn irgendwas wegschmeißen
müsste loca loca loca loca loca ich hab
den abgang zu einer höhle gefunden was
wo komm runter hier ist mein name ist
gerade nur ein stein schwert das heißt
man eben eisen schwer aber wir sehen uns
dann sofort wieder wenn ich bei max
ok meine damen und herren ich hab mir
jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen steak
gebraten ihr seht schon dieses dinge
unten funktioniert super man kann
einfach runter laufen ich bin jetzt hier
unten und du meintest vor hin dass du
hier vorne steht marc wo bist du ja hier
bin ich doch hier bin ich direkt steht
den ofen was halten die treppe dreht
kurz für horst schneider 50 mal weil
hier ist einfach direkt dass wir das
bisher nicht gesehen haben es
unglaublich direkten abgang zu einer
höhle das ist nicht irgendwie nur so ein
bisschen sondern es geht tief runter
aber wir gaben uns auf ein spannendes
höhlen abenteuer max runter kam habe ich
im camp astrid meinen ihr vieh finden da
unbestimmten höhle ich höre auch die
ganze zombies aber ich bin mir halten
nicht sicher ob die jetzt irgendwie
wirklich wegen uns hier sind oder ob die
wegen irgendwie oder wegen was wo warst
du hast wie was wieso sie kreml
sie sind jeweils kostenlose programm
jetzt hier unter max ich will in die
höhe gehen ja wie finden hier unten
lockern erhöhen safe keine höhle ein
paar schicken den später als ob jetzt
gerade direkt an ist wiederum weckers
lukas etwas zu sagen
willst du mich verarschen skelette
skelette spinnen spinnen alle gott oh
gott ich lasse lieber viel zu viel aus
und hab ich gar keine mehr als ich habe
keine aber naja ich glaube auch gerade
übrigens wieder nach oben bin nicht dumm
ich muss mal wieder in die andere
richtung laufen mag stellen wir doch
einfach nur eine frage was ist die
hauptstadt von kanada vancouver motto
was nicht vancouver
nein falsch du bist jetzt direkt die
vier weg es ist eine schaufel gut ich
hab das gerade in die ganze zeit
versuchen mit so einem quiz zu machen
aber man kann sie die fragen einfach
selbst überlegen denn das hatte ich eh
dass du das machst aber erst um kurz
genommen ist natürlich auch kurve direkt
noch eine frage stellen oder der hat die
glühbirne erfunden
komm schon das muss man wissen
ich habe keine ahnung von so was ich
habe auch nie wirklich in physik
aufgepasst was euch wegschmeißen
die 4 dann hab ich keine schaufel mehr
ich habe mir etwas schon von allen
sachen zwei mitgenommen eigentlich ist
dieses ganze eisen jahr komplett egal
ich baue das die ganze zeit ab weil ich
an war denken muss irgendwie und wir
alles eigentlich an rohstoffen
gebrauchen können aber wie soll das erst
mal was geht hier ab gehen wir dahin wo
es hier untergeht wenn wir hier runter
gehen kann ja hier links jetzt rum und
dann runter quasi das ziel der heutigen
folge ist es auf diamanten höhe zu
kommen und vielleicht den ein oder
anderen diamanten noch zu finden damit
wir das einfach mal von uns behaupten
können dass wir in dem projekt auch
schon die antennen gefunden haben aber
hat beweist ja schon dass nach wie vor
das ziel ist in sachen zu besiegen also
wir gehen in folge 10 egal was kommt in
cent und kämpfen
hier ist übrigens die heute zu ende ich
hoffe ich springform wer direkt die box
von den allen hero gottleuba weg hier
max und leuten unterwegs da könnt ihr
euch direkt vom pc hin wer hat den
dieselmotor erfunden und du musst nur
den nachnamen kennt den vornamen kenne
ich glaube ich auch hier ist die höhle
übrigens auch vorbei wer den dieselmotor
erfunden man was weiß ich locker mister
petrol gott was fest ich keine ahnung
wie gesagt ich weiß was nicht
dieselmotor hat rudolf diese entpuppten
frage nach circa 10.000 gefühlten jahren
max und ich haben uns da oben aus der
vorherigen höhle einfach unter gegraben
und sind jetzt hier auf eine andere
gestoßen direkt in dem lager heraus
gekommen ist aber auch keine die hasen
wie sie wissen ist gelüftet als selber
aufnehmen so unser projekt ich habe
andere als max aber die bringt die höhle
hier ist jetzt auch schon wieder nicht
so groß ja wir hatten eigentlich gedacht
so dass wir in irgendeiner höhle reihen
auf gott sind jetzt in den kreislauf
oder wie hier um mir vorbeigekommen
nicht im kreis gelaufen ist schon wieder
vorbei ich will einfach nur die
permanten finden damit wir sagen können
ja okay wie es ist jetzt folge sieben
glaube ich dass wir überhaupt in diesem
projekt man irgendwann diamanten
gefunden haben stehen wir doch einfach
ein allgemeinwissen frage kurz willst du
wirklich noch eine ja ich weiß nicht ob
ich damit jetzt nur zum affen habe ich
weiß halt einfach wirklich nicht so viel
über das allgemeine hey leute ich möchte
ich mal eben ganz kurz aus dem schnitt
ich wollte nur sagen dass es gerade 453
ist nicht dieses video hier gerade
mitten danach schneidet deswegen wollte
ich mich nur ganz kurz dafür
entschuldigen dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen öde ist oder ein bisschen
eintönig oder so aber ich bin einfach
hundemüde ich muss in vier stunden am
hauptbahnhof sein das heißt ich versuche
jetzt irgendwie noch zweieinhalb stunden
zu schlafen oder so ich hoffe euch
gefällt das video trotzdem irgendwie bis
hierhin und jetzt geht es weiter
ist noch eine kinokarte das ist jetzt
echt gemein war ich habe selbst auch
absolut gar keine ahnung von solchen
fragen wann war der erste weltkrieg
weiter der zweiten uns ich würde sagen
[Musik]
1919 100 ich weiß der zweite wagen die
1942 bis 1945 so um den dreh der erste
war ich sag mal 930 ein 1914 bis 1918
was willst du wegschmeißen wir erst
einmal die wester mal mit der 4
luca luca luca luca luka komme ja komm
ja cool ich hab die als mir egal mag
keine details bekannt rafter for server
kicken
ich hab dir ja es mag keine die ja die
haare gekriegt
hauptsache der ball direkt aber wir uns
gut gebaut haben wir haben uns den
hintern baut hier wir uns von ihr haben
wir uns runter gebaut und hinter dem red
storm war die ja gut wir haben ist
diamanten gefunden
ich schau doch mal ein bisschen weiter
ich meine du hast jetzt auf dieser höhe
hier gefunden also ist ja ja höher
vielleicht sind wir noch mehr ich weiß
nicht dass du genau wie sie spezielle
gemacht wir sind dann darauf höhe 10 das
ist die perfekte höhe
ich habe mir die dia spitzhacke gemacht
soll ich auch direkt genug ob sie den
abbauen dass wir uns unser portal machen
können ja stimmt stimmt wollen wir
überhaupt einen rapper wir sind so
schlecht
wir können schon mal ganz kurzen nenner
vorbeischauen
ich habe sogar ein feuerstein ich hab
jetzt reisen gerade nicht mit dabei aber
ich brate mal eben schnell was dann kann
ich auch schon mal eben schnell den
dings machen ein feuerzeug aber
vielleicht schaffen wir diese folgen
obwohl enchantment table als auch unser
portal des werden bgag ich denke dass
wir schaffen könnten ich bin in der
roder teil bei 36 minuten aber ich würde
deswegen sagen ich weiß einfach mal
einen schnellen übergang und 4c doch
sofort wieder nostra bono
neue levels wieder in unserer bruder
angekommen meinte wir sind nach oder
teil schon bei weit über einer halben
stunde deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen
wenn ihr wirklich sehen wollen wir den
netter gehen und wie wir einen tempel
bauen müsste auf jeden fall die nächste
folge minecraft mords bei max auf dem
kanal hier morgen abdecken denn durch
die folge gefallen hat würde ich mich
sehr über einen like freunde findet hier
eine 2 die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
wie könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren und
ihr findet hier drunter noch irgendein
anderes video eingeblendet also wenn ihr
noch weiter bock auf in welche videos
habt könnt ihr das geld einfach
anklicken das was ihr vom video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen und wir sehen
uns morgen einen weiteren partner max
wieder ciao